in a situationship where it's just he
doesn't like you she's never being in a
situationship okay fine everyone else
to my younger siblings or anything I'll
say at least if you're seeing a guy for
at least a minimum of nine months and he
hasn't made no like no indication that
he wants to make you his girl then yeah
you're just gonna have to keep it moving
otherwise he's going to be played the
full because he's just running game on
you for me I'd have to cut I'd have to
run with three months I'd still have to
run with it again and I forgot did you
say it takes you three months or it
takes you longer than that yeah three
months oh you said three months okay I
would say six six
I go for eight eight
six six
if I if I had the door off yeah because
it's just interesting because I see the
guy's point of view but I also see the
women's point of view if I had a
daughter or I was speaking to my my
sister or my nieces
in a group I would say to them
um if a guy hasn't committed to you
after a year
um then leave that guy and how long
would you want after the year of the or
three months to a year of a
situationship how long would it take you
guys to marry the girl
it um ideally would you guys want I
think in this day and age it's hard to
even answer that question because oh
wait actually I'm sorry sorry I have to
cut you off how many want to be married
raise your hand
okay okay so you you are married
okay
so for the guys that actually want to be
married how long would it take you it
depends so if I know that I want to
marry her yeah I could do it immediately
immediately yeah I don't even need any
type if I know everything about her I
know I don't like there's no guesswork I
don't need to I don't need to figure
stuff out if I know everything I need to
know about her I can just get married so
the the three to I think three to six
months is that what you said no I said
three months three months period of of
getting to know her you make her your
girlfriend you can marry her the next
year yeah okay okay uh cool so for me
I'd have to be seeing the girl for at
least five years before I propose and
then after five years I think then I
would propose and then I'd want at least
another two years whilst we're engaged
before we actually get married so we're
looking at seven years
I'm gonna have to agree with that one as
well I'm gonna do it seven years you
know traditional women don't do that
like it's not gonna happen you will end
up with a city girl because she's the
type that's gonna wait Ali I disagree
with you I know I know a lot of girls
that and that in a way honestly they've
made the right guy they have that
genuine desire for and get [ __ ] by it
there's a girl I know that's a virgin
and she's been she's like they're in her
mid-30s with the same dude and she still
she doesn't have a ring no kids and
she's running out of time for the right
guy yeah yeah okay oh like yeah I guess
I guess that's true but I don't know I I
live in a specific area I know a lot of
like Christian wives and husbands and
stuff so my perspective is like a little
bit different so yeah but I wouldn't
recommend it to my daughter I'd be like
come on girl no I agree I mean seven
years how how much do you guys think
weddings cost so the type of wedding I'm
trying to have isn't no wedding that's
just gonna be like that out the way see
why are we spending 10K in a wedding I
just don't get it like we can we can get
it we can go to the courthouse tomorrow
and that's the and that's the energy
that's that's sort of refreshing but I
hate your time scales but for me from so
I said three months relationship
including the three months though I'd
say two years engagement
and then another three years on top for
that for the for the wedding for me two
and then five so we're together five
years seven years no I said five years
before I propose seven years before I
get married
and then an extra free for a wedding so
five years all together okay five years
seven sorry Paul can I just ask them a
question so why'd the two years
engagement why so it's a plan so two so
two years to enjoy the relationship to
do the process to see if this is the
person you wanna
have children with because for me if I'm
not going to have children with the
person
then it is there's no point in in
marriage I'm not looking to get married
to have no children but you've given it
a ring doll
yeah but no that's why I said I said two
years to then get to that stage okay
awesome I said so from obviously I said
Fremont gets a relationship but from the
zero to after two years if I know this
person get engagement so not to not to
jump in the queue so so here's here's
where my one year of getting to know
each other comes in I would I would do
or pretty much most of that within that
one year I would have like for me to be
someone's boyfriend you've got oh I'm
not gonna get married I don't I don't I
don't really believe in marriage yeah
it's it's not impossible for me to get
married but it's not really would you do
it would you do a ceremony and not the
government potentially potentially But
but so in that one year of getting to
know that person and getting to know
each other it covers most of this so
that's so that's the thing like I
wouldn't even be your boyfriend if I
couldn't see you as a mother or a wife
okay I like you now so that so so that's
the that's the thing and and for me we
all have a different style and the thing
is everything's about like um that
thresholds right so it's just it's just
like cool so now after three months I
want to make you my my girlfriend now
after the after the girlfriend stage
we're working towards that now it's you
know I mean it's just like it's
different threshold it's not like I'm
putting them through tests I think just
I feel like it just makes why would you
make her your girlfriend if you have no
intentions of making her your wife I I
would never do that
that's what that's what I'm saying I
wouldn't it's just about it's just about
time and I'm not gonna make my
girlfriend next day engaged my next say
that that's what I'm saying about the
time skills so you think you could
identify a wife and you want to have
kids yeah yeah and a mother within three
months
what are you saying like that it's it's
wild like when you say like that but if
that's
what I'm saying is though if we're
saying that that even six months as well
but what I'm saying is to be in a
relationship with somebody after three
months if you're seeing each other two
times two times a week I personally
don't think that's wild same question
then in a different way so you would be
in a would you be in a relationship with
someone without knowing without feeling
like you can see them as the mother of
your children or your wife
would you be in a relationship with that
person
I don't think I would so you you've so
then what you're saying is you need a
longer period of time like me
that's the point of dating is to see if
you think that that it would be like
viable if you guys are compatible like I
actually what I think like most people
do that are into marriage I think
they'll date for a year I think they'll
get engaged for a year and then after
that year is up I think they'll get
married but that's the point I got
nothing wrong I mean I don't find
anything wrong uh with a long engagement
I think that that makes perfect sense I
think that's fair but a woman wants to
know that she's like off the market I
want to show something off and say hey
it's about communicating realistic time
frames I think that's what it's about if
you just say to her look at the minute
I'm not in a position to get engaged I
don't want to get engaged yet however
within a year year and a half that's and
stick into it that's the most important
thing I think this is why sometimes
women get um obviously annoyed because
they think your word is bond and it
should be so if you're saying to someone
look like when I met my wife I remember
we was at a wedding and one of her
friends tried to bring me on smoke and
say oh you guys not going to get engaged
yet or whatever but we already had that
conversation and said this is when we're
getting engaged just this sort of time
frame we're looking to get engaged when
we're looking to get mad etc etc but you
need to just be apparent to them and
stick by it so don't lead them on with
oh yeah maybe one day one day but then
again I know to flip for that I know
guys who have literally told their
current girlfriend that they're with
yeah I don't want to marry you so how
long and she still stayed with him and
she still stayed with it
okay okay guys I want to get through the
actual question so seven years seven
years you don't believe in marriage how
long for you
I would say a year a year and you could
get married yeah a year oh wow okay just
to change mine I'd say if they're like
you said if there was no ceremony okay
so you would you would do ceremony okay
how long would it take you to get to a
ceremony three years three years
like as the girl you get down the aisle
instead oh my God that would be
I I understand more than anyone like
where the guys are coming from but seven
years is a lot well you guys you guys
know we get smoke for that right like
people start looking at us funny like
you know it's like to be honest I'm not
even sure how many women would even get
married were it not for the female
social pressure
and that's not the woman that you want
to marry the one who's doing it for that
reason exactly no no I know but it's
there it's they look you can't get rid
of it if you're not married by 30 people
look at you funny no matter what so like
that that reality exists so like I
understand why you guys want to wait
yeah I'm just also making you guys aware
of the fact that like we do get looked
at funny the longer that we we hold on
to because people are like you don't
expect anything out of this but you know
why
um I actually I don't know why I just
know that girls do it there's a funny
joke in my community as well where the
girl is getting married to have the big
wedding and then she the joke is oh but
now she has to sleep with the husband as
well like I was suddenly the guy I'm
marrying wants to do more than cuddle
right yeah I understand but I got I got
married like super low budget um just
because we had it we were trying to get
it done but I had like my reception
of your partner before you got married
before I got married I think we this is
hard uh I think we were together for a
year and a half I think so that was when
we got married
mm-hmm
let's be I think I think people know
whether their partner is marriage
material quite early I'll say around
around six months to a year I think
people have made up their mind like you
know what
I can I'll take a bet on this one or
I'll pass on this one I'm sorry yeah so
I personally think if we're gonna take
that into account
the age of the woman how many kids you
want
I don't see the point of waiting seven
years if we meet a woman at 25 what
you're gonna wait five years so you're
gonna wait five years to find out if
she's the one seven years to propose but
she's 32 at that time
I'd actually also add most men have a
like a checklist in their head of what
they want their wife to like they have
certain things about their wife and they
want to make sure she has it doesn't
take that long to figure it out yeah
there's certain things you want you can
figure them out within three to six
months you can figure them out like if
you have literal checklists in your mind
does she do this can she do that you can
figure them out quickly you can
literally ask her you can ask questions
you can figure them out after time
things do show it doesn't take that long
to figure out your checklist and if you
if everything is checked on your
checklist I have no problem immediately
marrying because then I know I found the
one what do you guys think what do you
what do you guys think so the guys that
had so you two and who is the next
longest after seven years
oh five seven five did you say three
last of the year yeah are you two said
three yes as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible